it's not just what did somebody say
something
laughter bye
do I think we like him I think he said
hey if he helped her I think it's dumb
to trust strangers but this is something
we saw with you in the gun
give us a crystal or cover to do lock of
the door I don't Chris to take this one
and yeah that's not what happened inside
Amina you know I come to the door I hope
we can trust this guy I'd like to have a
go around
is it the guy yeah as you can see it's
quite good yeah I know Mikey Mike so
much more yes I know he wasn't do - now
I might just go happen again to be gutsy
are we gonna get burnt alive Robbo
yeah I think one can I mean they did yep
good Rex listen - yes
going on I should wash these things to
be very surprised to hear that
I'm so glad I didn't kill us no no
maybe go it says people monsters
I gotta help believe it tell me
shut up Mike can you not
somebody ate somewhere
Oh
does that mean just became what
or did they they respond because
something attacked just so what they did
for that
[ __ ]
I have been commercial
we're gonna be okay of Donnie okay all
right
yeah
okay
I feel pretty good about this I did do
it I think wherever skiing Chris and
Josh but I want Chris to go I think you
go to Troy and say yeah Josh it's only
9:00 he's just again he's just feel yes
all right I trusted I really like this
is one of my favorites no me too it
might might be as well if if Mike Witt
Mike them fully this guy's lead Mike
also doesn't care as much about
yeah all right yeah yeah I mean look the
thing is we don't know when who died I'm
just thinking because it's getting close
to the end of the game I think Emily
could've died in the mines I think that
that that thing that she was walking
towards the Florida thing yeah I reckon
that could have killed her if I had
screwed up a second QT okay all right
and she wouldn't die there I don't
really know
or they put Josh in the street I really
made it I think it was all Mike just
being really angry it might be because I
don't really get that did walking
towards the light
I'm really worried or I'm really worried
about this
I'll see you can stand still okay okay
cut me up stance don't see it because
they don't hate movement oh hey baby I
don't but that's what that meant without
getting a way that I could be really
still fighting - that's pretty still I
think okay well yeah yeah they're
telling me that because it's probably
gonna be one of those don't move moments
hey that's fun
I hope he's escaped I was
why don't you leave
soon
yeah because this now the American guy
he's gonna yeah yeah I think so we still
don't never let that dark thing hmm
what was that a break from life
be careful I'm very worried about Chris
yeah please follow Chris please [ __ ]
follow Chris come on come on check
stay with the guy who you who you Chris
Peters
no no no I meant to talk let's go soon
Oh didn't break that whole [ __ ] time
not gonna run run
stay still
oh no no that guy Oh God
stay still Chris oh [ __ ] I don't feel
very good without him you know what I
don't feel good with Chris moving in the
counties hopefully become it just gave
me the opportunity to UM shoot the
Wayfarers law
come over here come on Chris get
together me come on Chris [ __ ] still
it seems to like that it's freezing to
give me a vulture [ __ ] door shut the
door shut the [ __ ] door oh damn the
basement go go go nobody gets weird or
is it oh no sir Ellis is dead one
neither
oh it's Josh oh it's just Josh isn't so
just just just skimmed this wasted Josh
is probably not dead Chris definitely
would have died if I had me done that
shotgun bit then absolutely this is
getting really intense just
yep
just let me focus all lit up like the
break they cannot I dare to do it
quickly how about this Vince don't I
mean if you catch yourself in fine right
yeah they cannot go without food
all right Michael kind of [ __ ] me a bit
that [ __ ] inaudible Josh
and too much Chris
looking back the boy again Oh coming to
mind are you stupid
just stay where you are just stay there
couple hours big deal I'm like something
here 20 thinking so courageous he's
always making straight then let's go
check Mon yeah that's right
maybe the bag
Oh
what
right
Michael I'd like to be broken on Howard
you did the [ __ ] out of your plane piece
it's not how I might spot back through
yeah I'm annoyed that we didn't get to
see that
me me change
does that mean although maybe he did say
that uh did he say yeah you did
capitalist
hmm I don't know how to do like this
they need to look at the sky the
transformation can be instant it would
be something that would be progressive
or I'd be seeing I always think so but
we don't know if Chris is still left
really
you're just making yourself feel better
about leaving languages leaving there
with seventh why rock-type yeah if they
don't you'll just break out of it buddy
they can't break into a building like
that guys it didn't stop I think that
they are friends strong enough to get
out of in type of chap don't do it
that's that was the time
that's fortune let's charge so maybe she
wants on new tonight
no that's what Silas
mmm-hmm definitely keep an eye on her I
feel like she'll be fine
I don't know you know I don't either I
think that they probably should turn up
yeah they should zip tie the hell out of
how they should chain another [ __ ]
wall let's do something so that she's
contained yes come on on waiting he's
[ __ ] man enough to find Josh why
don't you yet what an idiot
I mean Angela's just a weird fad about
Emily
no she's looking at Chris
and you do is not only their colleague
yeah mrs. book
when givers of money puked I dipped with
the Windigo I must be good tonight so I
won't keep reading that it's virtually
Odessa doesn't okay the loss the Windigo
it must be contained we do good Rosa I
cannibalism my humor is desperate
encouraging trap technology it's fine
just don't eat nothing for many days eat
the flesh it doesn't say and become
milky and white yeah absolutely
so maybe he's that know what that mean
red wasn't about Hanna and Beth it was a
bank ago absolutely what's about the
Windigo 42 years anymore they've been up
there for that long so we need to
concern him is always a good guy we need
to contain the girl and that means that
Hanna Beth want murdered if it fell to
Melanie no no but that was this thing
whether the Ouija board said that
they've been murdered maybe that was set
up by Josh as well maybe chocolate the
may also manipulate event and that never
happens so that that whole thing's young
a highly likely to break them out then
the chief become longer like fangs
wonder what happens bit John that's very
noisy
it shows an accountant winning
objectives real and dangerous you really
see what that means but if do not humble
dances the evidences story in my
experience
why is local man funded so maybe some of
the stuff that was written into that
might fund in the Senate Williams this
was what the cover-up in the most so
that this these things been a gracious
man as traveling these mountains called
the creations
every animal became sacred also with its
we had to look up spammable I think
that's the game coming it's not going
out no we knew that from the start and
did meet you said that it said that this
dog not too busy I remember it saying
that someone sending a comment I don't
remember it up saying that but we palm
down make you we didn't we didn't have
we didn't have nobody over no never do
that like yeah I feel so we made do that
those two can fallen off the mountain we
didn't hurt them okay the cram believed
it was bad right
Oh Swiss no mohammad analyst in 1983 the
one is a writer fountain and late traces
of wearing him crease a blow to blow
when he his eyes become shop
count it's a stillness we have to
remember that keep totally still okay
totally still the wedding will not be
able to use trying not to kill so can't
be consoling the Windigo
try an optical should be the last resort
death releases them into your spirit in
today and how it contains them [ __ ]
so how these are christa skill that five
you didn't kill any of them yes he do
the bullets will not finish their skin
they were shot and will keep them at bay
I don't think you killed any other so
they come away okay um hey Jeannie
killed say I was six windigos try not to
kill them sweeps week in them the
pointer all we can go I can get a
splinter oh it's got lots of traps traps
were baited with human lives from those
who had no go to use of them so he
probably did use and that's dead buddies
yeah which is what hit their heads
perhaps but that's Sperry off with a
little information to absorb and I feel
like it's important what just say
something bad about someone did
where's that it just came up on that
level from the bite of creel in and say
the way to go groups in the by him
another one you know but the fight is
harmless I've been bitten but I did not
change good
so if she'll like she's cool
reading this okay there we go and report
that to Emily yes Emily's fine release
why would be reassuring it I love it
[ __ ] would you do the other answer maybe
some people won playing in the creepy
way good you should go home
is the able to die
the good news will help elaborate on
what not to shoot she's rich October we
told my not to shoot no sir I think to
do it thank god you're going to try fit
a minute whoa
I can't believe Mike went by yourself
it's stupid I'm kind of mad at him
that's really stupid only Chris did you
stress forsensheffy a did I think this
whole thing's in his imagination like
this main stretches probably still alive
Deena - which is Priscilla yeah
definitely dead no no he's in his head
this is what this what he's yeah yeah
the commented centrist especially ones
the Washington's gonna forward doing any
of this
you know sensei
Yang's a lot if he's thinking this then
he's a lot yeah man it's Josh it is a
split personality this is the other side
of him
maybe I mean he keep fashioning effects
I knocked her out
yeah could not be other the other answer
was it was just a game versus sorry no I
don't feel right controlling these
answers like it shouldn't be up to me to
decide I'm sorry
I'd say sorry yeah but would Josh say
that I don't know they should I don't
think he would say that depending on
what state of mind he's a know whatever
it's good to see it doesn't feel right
for me to get to control that it so
because that's not my Enzo it's that's
up to him you know